maíam fritzy reacts I am @h NPI cease
teaching the boys are to run restaurants
and business skills but right now today
we are making Vesta fresh tagliatelle
I'm clay Burley I've presented program
and my past is gonna be better than his
that's what she thinks let battle
commence gentlemen and as you can see
some people are very good at making tell
you but not so good at making better
some people are very good at making tell
you I'm very good at making pasta let's
see who that might be
tell me about how you got involved with
this wreck
well I've started to work with the
advantage kids for the last 10 years
yeah and I came to Isis he became just
very quickly obvious to me that he'd be
so simple to set up a restaurant and
teach offenders the art of running
restaurant business skills and to
inspire them to live a law-abiding life
and basically to reduce reoffending by
the same token see me tell me why you
get involved I love doing well on the
out once I've got the qualification yeah
needed one of the key force kado is to
ensure that we have enough support from
employers because there is a stigma
attached to employing offenders and
people believe that if you employ an
ex-offender then they will all sort of
bad things to you I've employed acts of
ex-offenders for a long time have never
had any problem have you found that
people who treat you differently because
you've been in prison
what difference is it gonna make for you
[Music]
get confirmation from us my time you
decide here wisely
this is all school pasta making game
yeah no nonsense with machine and stuff
like that yeah we're doing everything by
hand I'm still waiting for cables
perspective yeah House is resting as if
not showing off houses resting we're
just gonna make a prayer to the st.
Padre Pio the Italian Saint and maybe we
come can always cheat and just throw
against the wall hey go it's not quite
ready that's a good
that's a good question one thing that we
teach the boys here is about timing and
precision because when it's time for
service it's like when caber lay is
ready to go live on television you've
got to be ready and then of course if
it's ready to early it goes cold that's
right but we are ready to go yeah but
it's too early
come on we've just met our guests they
are very hungry cheating is cheating
carry the plate like that like this yeah
well done that's it this way you can put
it down without disturbing the guests so
you serve it to these two guests here on
that side actually serve it to the two
ladies because we always give the best
to the ladies first
sorry guys enjoy
[Music]
awkward everything is salvageable it's
called a disaster in the kitchen and is
presented by Kia Burley so we're gonna
go with Plan B which involves few chips
like this bit of salt on your chips guys
it's already salted can I just say that
the capacity to adapt is very important
in restaurant and K is showing some
great skills there I'm impressed
if the guests all that passed I wanted
passed on are they gonna get rice and
chips perfectly balanced meal so
gentlemen we decided that the pasta was
just so passe so instead we've gone with
rice and because your chaps we've got
chips to go on the side as well thank
you thought that maybe you wanted some
pesto so enjoy looks amazing don't you
think
let's go species from within you know
life is not fair is another example what
do you think I think it's a fantastic
charity I think we should absolutely
roll it out into every prison CMD prison
in the country and I think if they're
watching at the Ministry of Justice
today can we give it a go it's easy to
set up we're all ready to go you want
some pasta
[Music]